[Music]
Sleeping Beauty this movie always
astounds me in what a colossal epic and
what a colossal mess it is both at the
same time first let's look at the good
stuff the artwork for example is a very
different take for Disney the
backgrounds never look three-dimensional
but they're not supposed to it's
supposed to be very much like tapestry
work or like paintings you'd see in a
medieval castle it was a very different
approach and it looks very nice though I
guess at times it can be a little
distracting for some viewers I
personally don't mind though let's also
look at the side characters the fairies
are great they have to hide the Princess
Aurora for 16 years to keep her away
from the evil of Maleficent who again is
frigging great I mean one of the best
villains top three easily
it's a villain that's evolved almost
entirely from the voice acting and the
animation cuz be fair her motivations
not very strong she gets snubbed at a
party that's it but the extreme she'll
go to get revenge
now that's friggin awesome before the
Sun sets on her 16th birthday she shall
prick her finger on the spindle of a
spinning wheel and die
she's classy she's despicable she's
quiet she's loud she's subtle she's
over-the-top she's everything you want
in a villain she can wave her hand and
make something move or she can turn into
a fire-breathing dragon friggin awesome
the music is also fantastic taken from
one of the best-known ballets under the
same name it leads to some memorable
songs as well as some great climax music
in fact the climax itself is one of
Disney's best the energy the animation
everything that goes into it is just
fiery blaze
[Music]
it's always the best part of the movie
every time I watch it
now let's get to the stuff that doesn't
work like the main characters good god
are they boring when I think of a
stereotypical boring princess this is
who I think of she does nothing she has
little to no character she just sort of
sings and looks pretty I don't even
think she's that pretty but how about
the prince he's the dashing hero in the
end surely he must be interesting right
actually he's even more boring do you
realize that the last line he says in
this movie is goodbye father and that's
about half way through after that he
doesn't get a line he just runs around
swinging his sword that's it at least
she has an excuse she's put to sleep for
the second half him Kumi get a grunt or
an oomph for himself
there's also a lot of filler in this
movie and maybe that's one of the
reasons why the main characters are so
bland I think this movie really liked
its side characters much more most of
the time is spent with the fairies the
villains the two kings that really
doesn't lead to anything so really it's
a very unbalanced film but again I guess
like most Disney films the stuff that
works well works really really well
the villain is great the fairies are
great the animation is great that ending
fight scene is just friggin fantastic so
it's kind of hard to judge this movie
seeing how not only does they have some
good things but it has some of the best
of any of the Disney films but it goes
beyond just typical visuals it actually
does have some very good characters even
if they are the side characters for that
I think it holds up for several viewings
I did see this film quite a few times
growing up and I did like it every time
there's just several scenes I liked a
lot more than others but they are good
scenes and they are good characters so
from a storytelling point of view the
film probably doesn't work but just from
a selfish point of view in terms of
seeing something that you've never seen
before or something that's done really
really well there's a lot of things to
enjoy even if it turns out on the whole
you don't like the film I still think
it's worth looking at the stuff that's
impressive is still really impressive I
know I'm not done watching it and I'm
sure one or two more views are not far
in my future
[Music]